let's jump to the story from the Daily
Mail I saw actually this tweet first
from Jack besobic woke Disney Sparks
outrage with new kids cartoon that
claims America was built on slavery as
it pushes reparations and says Lincoln
had no desire to liberate the enslaved
that last part's true Lincoln had no
desire to liberate the enslave that's a
fact anybody who reads about Civil War
knows that even the Emancipation
Proclamation only applied to States and
Rebellion from the United States meaning
there were several uh northern states
that had slavery that were exempt from
it however I think this is uh
what we were just talking about is the
desperate attempt to generate tribalism
form for money mission driven
storytelling because an entertainment
product won't cut it anymore and I think
that's what this is more about but this
also results I mean look at look at this
is what they're teaching your kids
the U.S still has not atoned for slavery
and look how pissed off these characters
are you're supposed to your kids are
going to watch this and they're going to
see a bunch of angry young people saying
United States is not a toned for this
and they demand reparations when in
reality the United States has in my
opinion more than atoned in in a lot of
ways and in ways that it's not
politically correct to talk about and
that no one none of these people have an
honest conversation with you about and
they will teach your kids because two
things are happening one the industries
are dying they need to find a way to
make money how are they going to do it
okay let's we're not going to get a
general audience anymore General
audience is no longer a thing with the
decentralization of the internet and
streaming platforms you need directed
audience you need a core audience choose
what your audience is when I worked for
Fusion they said our target audience are
young progressives and that means we are
going to side with them and tell the
stories they want to hear outright sang
as a media company we are here to say
what they want to hear deliver them a
product not we try and capture everybody
and tell them the news that was their
mission that's what this is and so what
I see here is is the other thing is
it's the long game man
you're gonna you're gonna sit here and
be like well you know it's one show
whatever those kids are going to grow up
it's the only thing they're going to
hear because people are too scared to
speak up and then this is what they're
getting from their from from Disney and
parents thinking in their minds Disney
is like Bambi are buying this for their
kids but instead their kids are being
told that America sucks has never atoned
and you know angry it's what you're
going to end up with is a group of young
people who are extremely unhappy
hopeless and pissed off well I think
when you said long ball another thing
came to my mind which is there's a lot
of people Americans born and raised
Americans and big powerful positions all
throughout our country that dream of the
day where America is no longer a
stand-alone independent entity they want
to see one world money one world
Military One World Medicine one world
everything and you can't have one world
anything as long as the United States is
still standing on both feet and able to
hold its own so if you can
disincentivize kids brainwash them and
grow them up into a young adult of
military age that is not willing to
fight for their country they don't think
their country is worth fighting for
guess what they won't fight for their
country and they won't be too upset if
somebody wants to come in here and take
the place over take it down you know if
you think about the World War II
generation had the great benefit of
being around grandparents uh my
granddaddy multiple purple hearts in
World War II you around those people you
know my grandmother's dragging metal in
from the ditches around Texas to the
schoolyard where they would melt it down
and turn it into tanks and airplanes and
bullets
that's what they had to do to save not
only United States but the whole world
you don't have that attitude with a lot
of young people right now and stuff like
this Disney crap you say parents think
that Disney's teaching their kids
showing their kids something good more
and more parents Tim are waking up to
the fact that Disney does not have the
best interests of their kids at heart I
can promise you you can look at the
stats on how many people are visiting
Disney right now it is plummeting
because people realize hang on these
people are trying to brainwash my kids
these people are trying to teach my kids
instead of me teaching my kids now I
don't know who in her as kids maybe I'm
the only one but nothing we talked about
this last time I was with you nothing
will bring out the vicious teeth of a
mom or a dad more whether they're a
left-leaning parent Center or
right-leaning parent nothing brings
their teeth out faster than thinking
some stranger is taking their autonomy
and Authority away from their own
household that is when the fists come up
and so Disney's just doing it on a
multi-billion dollar level but again
it's like the Grammys it's so blatant
now we used to accuse them of you know
what they're really trying to do right
and they'd say oh go put your tenfold
hat back on they're not doing that well
we don't have to accuse them of it
anymore because it's right in front of
our faces and parents are waking up to
it so good I'm glad Disney is doing that
it's just another another strike against
them as far as I'm concerned one of the
most frustrating things about the whole
woke ideology is one it's
I mean look if you want to make an
argument about slaves building the
country and operations we can have the
conversation doesn't necessarily have to
be rooted in critical race Theory and
stuff but the critical race Theory stuff
is resulting in segregation racial
animosity and there's been numerous
polls I think Gallup ran a poll that
said people view racial tensions in this
country worse now you know after the
Obama presidency than before like
following his presidency all we got from
the left was race race race race
and and this is you know I'm growing up
in a world where they're passing laws
and and uh there's court rulings to end
discrimination based on race and you end
up now with this the U.S has still not
atoned for slavery which is just
generating in my opinion more racial
animosity that you know I'll put it this
way when I said that I think this
country more than atoned how about how
many people died in the in the Civil War
like 1.8 million or something like that
yeah now granted there's a lot of
Confederates there but let me just point
out the Confederacy doesn't exist
anymore it's gone and so so after the
the the states that wanted slavery were
crushed in one of the most bloody
military conflicts ever I'd have to
argue that the north
militaristically crushing The South was
and then all of the all of the
Northerners who oppose slavery uh and it
wasn't completely about slavery mind you
I understand that but the end of slavery
brought about to the Civil War I think
is uh it counts as atonement on the part
of the north at the very least and the
South no longer exists after the South
Was Defeated they were occupied by
Northern forces in the Reconstruction
Era which didn't end until there was
almost another civil war so when they
come out and they're like this country
still hasn't atoned I'm like I don't
know I kind of think like half a million
800 000 dead soldiers fighting to end
the expansion of slavery at the very
least which resulted in the end of
slavery sounds like atonement for me uh
to me and then also keep in mind that
much of the country's expansion and
development have to happened after this
in fact one of the key components of the
Civil War was that Abraham Lincoln was
saying I I could be getting this wrong
it's been a while to write about and
there's people who know more than me
obviously
academics but what was really happening
was the current state of politics was to
stop the expansion of slavery into new
territories as they became States so
California for instance was never a
slave state it entered as a free state
it was always a free state and so that
was it was ending the expansion slavery
was was being
suppressed essentially so they want to
argue was never atoned for but I'm like
man Not only was the political
environment to shut it down slowly over
time with massive resistance those who
tried to keep it were crushed with
military force and you want to talk
about atonement how about Sherman's
March to the Sea and the decimation of
family homes and cities and Villages or
the ransacking and burning of Richmond
this this kind of stuff pisses me off
because it's a bunch of ideological
blowhards and they put out these videos
I watched one where This Woman's like we
should abolish private property also I'm
moving into my own house it is it it is
psychotic lunacy that's going to result
in in my opinion all of these good
things that we've retained while getting
rid of the bad will be destroyed we'll
be wiped out and then we'll all be left
holding empty bags in the middle of the
woods fending for ourselves yeah I was
gonna say this show The Proud Family
aired in the early 2000s so I remember
watching it as a kid and I'm kind of sad
to see them injecting this very
obviously uh pointed ideology into it
because it was one of the first TV shows
I remember seeing I think it is the
first time I remember seeing uh Muslim
characters depiction on television yeah
true there's like a whole episode where
she like the penny the main character
does kind of like an exchange but it's
within her own School District with a
Muslim family and just uh where hijab
and like talk about it and whatever else
and like there are ways to talk about
culture and ways to talk about the
challenges different people face coming
into America without it being like let's
all blame one person and let's have it
be about how this country is bad you
know this show is actually interesting
and this is the reboot I wish they would
have stuck with what they were trying to
do in the early 2000s like inclusion
diversity equity and inclusion that's a
big part of the critical race theory is
the inclusion of it so why exclude why
why talk about evil and them and those
if you really want to include people in
the process and I will also say we this
country was born on the backs of British
slave British subjects British subjects
that had to fight a war to overthrow
their slave master King George
the whole thing all of us come from
slaves can you name another country that
fought a civil war
over slavery in large part name any
other nation in the history of the
planet
they've all had slaves every Empire had
slaves is there any other one that
fought a civil war to end it now that I
think I'm going to think I think it's
just us yeah I'm gonna start look
searching because maybe there is I don't
know one off the top of my no they come
out for these kids young uh the the CRT
stuff
um that even landed in a little too
close to home a few years ago and I I
read it and I'm looking at it and I'm
thinking about there's my son sitting
next to his best friend who he plays
baseball with who's black
my son's a white kid and they're both
reading the same thing and it's saying
if you're this color then this is what
you're about and if you're that color
you don't have a chance and these both
these kids are looking at each other
going my son felt like he needed to
apologize he's like man I didn't know
you know they're little kids and the
other kid felt terrible because he's
like what do you mean I don't have a
chance we both hit home runs last
weekend it's all negativity oh it's
terrible it is mind torture right yeah
it's it's just it's disgusting well and
like this is his best friend right are
they going to spend the rest of the time
they go to school they're being like Oh
wait there's actually something terrible
they would if they didn't have parents
that told them hey that's nonsense
that's true and a lot of kids don't have
parents like that you're right A lot of
them don't yep
I I I'm trying to follow up on this it
looks like maybe Brazil fought a
revolution to overthrow slavery was this
Pedro Emperor Pedro I'm getting this all
wrong I need more data it's like sign up
to look at quora I don't want to sign up
guys well in uh in the UK they they uh
abolished slavery I think a couple
decades before the United States did so
the argument from a lot of these people
is that if the U.S never had
Independence
and it was just a colony of the UK
slavery would have ended a lot sooner I
kind of don't think so I think the Civil
War would have just been the southern
Revolution I mean that's basically what
it was the Confederacy was trying to
secede from the union make their own
country and if the UK was doing the same
thing I'd imagine they would have done
the exact same thing the only difference
is they'd be fighting against the the
crown
I don't know what the strength of the
crowns at that point it'd be a really
interesting history to see like the War
of 1812 actually ends up as some kind of
conflict over slavery or probably not
because I think it was like 1830 or
whatever the UK finally abolished it or
something like that but I don't know man
long story short
I think the people who write this stuff
they just have no idea what they're
talking about and that's a lot of what
guides culture in uh for humans
and man I don't know it's kind of
depressing right uh Bill Maher did this
really great segment I guess last week
talking about how cultural
revolutionaries want to erase human
nature and you can't Mao wanted to get
rid of the four Great olds or whatever
old culture and stuff like that and you
can't do it
and then he says in the Soviet Union
they had this idea of like the strong
Soviet man who cared more about being
part of a collective than of
individualism and then Bill Maher makes
the joke that um when in reality the
Soviet man just wanted to wear a
tracksuit be on a yacht with a beautiful
woman and then he chose a guy in a
tracksuit or whatever but the thing
about the reason I bring up Bill Maher
is that you know he's very much in line
with a lot of this stuff too notably his
Prager you uh uh I'm sorry his Prager uh
interview not interview but the
conversation when he was on the panel
and Prager said they're putting tampons
in the men's room and and Bill Maher
laughed at him like Bill Maher may be
doing better than a lot of these
mainstream default liberal types when it
comes to not under uh when it comes to
understanding some of the news and
what's happening in our culture but even
he's behind and so you end up with Bill
Maher who's supposed to represent like a
higher class of political commentary you
know it's it's smarter than Jon Stewart
but still funny things like that and
even they don't have any any idea what
they're talking about they're not
reading current news they're not talking
about current cultural issues they're
behind the curve by a couple years
so I don't know man uh part of me is not
particularly hopeful to be completely
honest if everything is racist then
nothing is racist yeah true and so the
best way to keep people fired up about
racism because I believe that that
people that push crap like this they
want to see racism they need to see
racism they need that hatred to exist so
they have a reason to go out and make
the money that they make doing whatever
it is the angle that they're pushing and
so you know the best way to do that is
anybody that I disagree with I'm going
to call them a racist yeah and then the
other person goes we weren't even
talking about that what do you mean I'm
a racist they go no you're a racist you
just don't know it that's part of the
CRT thing is you don't even know that
you're a racist but you are it's like
trust me it's like vaccines and fisa
right yeah you know you need another one
now you need a booster now you need
another thing like if you solved racism
who would fund all these non-profits
right like exactly what happened to me
in 2016 best friend in La we were
talking talk politics every day pretty
much well we would watch Rachel Maddow
and he'd have CNN on the backgrounds
talking about Hillary Clinton's emails
and their servers and like oh my gosh
look at what she did with Sydney
Blumenthal with Osprey Global Solutions
in Libya at a gun run for you know it's
basically privateering he's getting
Sydney Bloom with all this money and
he's like you're white privilege you've
got white like it just came down to
you've got white privilege and I it was
the first time I'd ever been told that
in my life and I was like what the hell
is going on I'm talking about Hillary's
emails dude look look at the data and
he's like you're just you're just racist
you're white your white privilege is
coming out and it was shocking blown uh
powerless I didn't know how to respond
how no wasn't enough no I'm not isn't
enough if they keep saying it over and
over and I just had to disengage I left
I haven't talked to the guy Harley it's
really one of the worst things you can
call somebody what's what's worse
than being called a racist well there's
a lot worse things I don't know I mean
that's like if you were actually a
racist like a real racist that's one of
the nastiest humans around if you're an
actual racist I mean I've run into a
couple of them and you're like wow I
don't want you know I mean they're
they're really nasty people uh from from
all sectors of the world that that are
true racist so when you're called one
and you're not one and that word gets
thrown around so flippantly it
at this point it almost has lost lost
its sting because everything like I said
if everything's racist then nothing is
racist most countries in the world are
extremely racist the United States in my
opinion is the least racist place I've
ever been totally I think Sweden may
have been one of the most racist places
I've ever been you know and and uh they
they masquerade as opposing racism but
then they're like super racist you know
I mean they can think that they're not
racist because they have homogeneous
society right like this argument gets
mean about Japan all the time they're
very strict on immigration you cannot
live in Japan but Sweden's issue is that
they they kind of don't they have
pockets of racial minorities from other
parts of the world that they've boxed in
claimed they're they're they're not
racist and then segregate these people
from their own society and refuse to
hire them while acting like they're all
Progressive that's that's what I mean
like at least in Japan they're honest
about them being like our country is
Japan for the Japanese so you can't come
here Sweden's like oh we love and care
about everybody you know they're allowed
to come here everybody in the and then I
I heard this from a lot of people even
Americans I heard an American woman who
moved to Sweden saying that they
wouldn't hire her because she had an
accent she spoke Swedish but had an
accent and they were like nope
there's like no integration did you get
that too traveling around you've been
around how many countries have you lived
in search
um I have no idea probably like 10 or so
you were nodding when Tim was saying
America's United States is the least
racist Yeah by far and people just don't
realize that because they've rarely been
other places so they often talk from an
American perspective about these things
and think that you know people in for
instance China oh they're not they're
like not they're extremely racist if
they're Han Chinese against even other
Chinese like people within China thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time